[Música]
repudio e indignación por la muerte de
una salvadoreña a manos de cuatro
policías mexicanos en tulum el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
condenó enérgicamente el asesinato y
afirmó que victoria salazar arriaza de
36 años había sido objeto de un trato
brutal el hecho generó protestas en
mexico mientras en el salvador piden
justicia
avanza en minneapolis el juicio contra
el ex policía derecho bin acusado de
asesinar por asfixia al afroamericano
georges lloyd el abogado de la familia
de floyd consideró que el juicio es un
referendo sobre la libertad de la
justicia de eeuu durante la primera
jornada a cerca de 200 manifestantes
pidieron justicia
paraguay está al borde del colapso
sanitario por cuenta de la pandemia de
kobe 19 la presencia y otras variantes
de el coronavirus podría ser la
responsable del aumento sostenido de los
casos aunque tampoco se descarta que la
relajación de la población haya llevado
a esta situación de saturación de
hospitales en todo el país
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 será blanco como siempre un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos en mexico
donde la muerte de la salvadoreña
victoria salazar a manos de cuatro
policías en la ciudad de tulum ha
generado el repudio de toda la sociedad
asociaciones feministas y de migrantes
condenaron la muerte de victoria que fue
sometida durante un operativo policial
el presidente de méxico condenó la
violencia machista que en su país mata a
10 mujeres al día mientras tanto el
presidente del salvador dijo estar
seguro de que el gobierno mexicano
aplicará todo el peso de la ley
una escena que ha causado conmoción en
el salvador y en méjico
pero también la muerte de la salvadoreña
victoria salazar a manos de cuatro
policías en la ciudad de tulum pesó en
la inauguración del foro generación
igualdad la conferencia internacional
que se celebra en la ciudad de mexico
busca determinar acciones concretas para
avanzar hacia los objetivos en materia
de igualdad fijados por la onu para el
2030 sin embargo durante la ceremonia de
apertura la atención recayó en la
condena del homicidio de victoria
salazar la mujer salvadoreña muerta a
manos de la policía mexicana el pasado
sábado a causa de una fractura en la
columna durante su violenta detención
desde el día mismo del asesinato el
mandatario salvadoreño nadie buque le
pidió justicia estoy seguro que el
gobierno mexicano aplicará todo el peso
de la ley a los responsables mi pésame
para la familia de victoria sobre todo a
sus dos hijas
el presidente mexicano aseguró que no
habrá impunidad para los policías
implicados en la muerte de salazar que
serán procesados por feminicidio
castigados los responsables de este
crimen
brutal
vergonzoso
y dolorosos
por otro lado el presidente francés y el
secretario general de naciones unidas
pronunciaron discursos más amplios de
denuncia a la brecha y a la violencia de
género acentuada por la pandemia y el
kobe 19 también nos ha recordado la
persistencia de la violencia que sufren
las mujeres esta pandemia en la sombra
que se alimenta de las situaciones de
confinamiento en el exterior del palacio
nacional la protesta de un grupo de
mujeres recordaba que la cercanía de la
muerte de salazar con la celebración del
foro no es una coincidencia temporal en
méjico diez mujeres son asesinadas cada
día
y precisamente ante la violencia
policial ayer lunes comenzó uno de los
juicios más seguidos de las últimas
décadas el de derecho a bing el ex
policía acusado por el asesinato de
george flow en mayo de azul 20 el juicio
se centró en esclarecer las causas del
fallecimiento del afroamericano para lo
que la parte acusadora utilizó el vídeo
de la muerte de floyd como prueba
principal con este material audiovisual
en el que se ve como floyd no puede
respirar contestó al argumento del
abogado de la defensa que aseguró que la
víctima abuso de medicamentos debido a
una dolencia cardíaca
el informe salva santana
diez meses después del caso que reabrió
la herida racial en estados unidos la
muerte del afroamericano church floyd el
ex policía acusado por su asesinato
directo a bing se sentó en el banquillo
de los acusados el juicio se centra en
esclarecer la causa de la muerte de
floyd la acusación usó el vídeo del
fallecimiento de la víctima más de nueve
minutos en los que se puede ver al ex
policía con la rodilla en el cuello de
floyd mientras él clamaba que no podía
respirar un rato más
mándela sexualidades cejas cuando esto
pues guay ustedes aprenderán que en los
últimos nueve minutos y 29 segundos de
vida del señor floyd en ese periodo de
tiempo se puede ver como su muerte
encaja con la de alguien que muere por
falta de oxígeno podemos señalar la
evidencia en el vídeo lo podrán ver
ustedes mismos
también verán evidencias de lo que no
fue no fue por ejemplo un paro cardíaco
fatal no fue por ejemplo un ataque al
corazón pero howard
así contestó la acusación al abogado de
la defensa que sostuvo que floyd tuvo un
paro cardíaco provocado por el abuso de
medicamentos y una dolencia cardíaca y
pidió aplicar el sentido común en el
juicio de chauvín
wes el sentido común nos dice que
siempre hay dos lados en una historia y
el sentido común nos dice que tenemos
que examinar la totalidad de las
circunstancias que determinan el
significado de las pruebas y cómo se
pueden aplicar a las cuestiones de la
razonabilidad de las acciones y
reacciones
pero algunos de los primeros testigos
que empezaron a dar testimonio también
constataron el uso excesivo de fuerza
por parte de la ex policía
y cuanto más tiempo pasaba con la
rodilla en el cuello más se podía ver
como floyd se iba desvaneciendo fairway
la muerte de floyd desencadenó las
mayores protestas por la igualdad racial
de eeuu en las últimas décadas y la
sentencia del caso marcará un antes y un
después para la comunidad afro
vamos hasta paraguay donde hay
preocupación de las autoridades por la
presencia de otras variantes de coke 19
que podrían ser las responsables del
aumento sostenido de los casos sumado a
una posibilidad de relajación de la
población el ministerio de salud informa
de 1.770 positivos en las últimas 24
horas del total de casos asciende a
210.000 425 en cuanto a la cifra de
muertos a causa de la enfermedad en las
últimas horas se notificaron 50 personas
fallecidas totalizando así 4113 decesos
asimismo las hospitalizaciones
aumentaron considerablemente desde
asunción nuestro corresponsal fernando
bottía con los detalles
paraguay está atravesando una nueva ola
de contagios de kobe 19 que está
sacudiendo el sistema sanitario público
y privado ya son más de 200.000 los
contagios y 4000 las muertes por la
enfermedad hace más de un mes el país
está batiendo continuamente su récord de
contagios y muertes diarias y el
gobierno atribuye este aumento acelerado
a que la variante brasileña del virus
que es más infecciosa ya está circulando
de forma comunitaria en distintos puntos
del país con una ocupación del 100 por
ciento de camas de terapia el presidente
mario abdo benítez decidió decretar una
nueva cuarentena durante la semana santa
con el objetivo de disminuir los
contagios y descomprimir los hospitales
a todo esto hay que sumar que el país
mantiene uno de los peores registros de
vacunación en todo el continente apenas
36 mil personas fueron vacunadas contra
el coi 19 en paraguay para contrarrestar
este déficit el gobierno aceptó una
donación de 100 mil dosis de la vacuna
coec sinde india sin embargo esto generó
nuevas críticas a la administración de
abdo benítez debido a que esta vacuna
aún no tiene el aval de una entidad
regulatoria internacional y por lo tanto
no será administrada todavía la
población paraguaya
los jefes de estado de gobierno de 25
países respaldaron la propuesta de la
unión europea de crear el tratado contra
las pandemias con la finalidad de
construir una arquitectura sanitaria
internacional más sólida que proteja a
las generaciones futuras y garantice un
acceso universal a las vacunas la
propuesta fue apoyada por el director
general de la organización mundial de la
salud
pedrosa nong ebre 'jesús y el presidente
del consejo europeo charlie es él quien
lanzó esta idea en nombre de los
veintisiete- en otoño pasado ahora se
espera que la propuesta esté lista en
mayo
peter stott as one router les nos ha
enseñado una lección brutal ningún país
ningún continente puede derrotar una
pandemia sólo requiere un enfoque global
en nosotros en lugar del yo y un
compromiso colectivo al más alto nivel
político
no es y habrá otra pandemia cómo será
así que debemos estar preparados que
perder
twist tres de los principales grupos
étnicos armados de mianmar lanzaron un
ultimátum a la junta militar del país al
amenazar con anular su acuerdo el alto
el fuego si continúa la matanza
indiscriminada de manifestantes la
advertencia de los grupos guerrilleros
se produce tras el fin de semana más
sangriento hasta el momento que ha
llevado la cifra de muertos a 510 según
estadísticas publicadas por la
asociación para la asistencia de presos
políticos de mianmar
hasta que el informativo continúe con
nosotros
[Música]
r efe y france 24